前髪が少し戻ってきたな
そんなにかなぁ
わかんないなぁ
俺は余裕だと思ってるよ
はい今回はこちら
ベジマイト
日本のやつじゃにないんですけどもジャムですね
ジャムというかちょっとパンにかけて食べるジャムらしいんですけど
これが
少し前までね、私嘔吐系YouTuberとして有名でした。
ちょっと出ちゃった
というわけで今回はこのベジマイトを食べてみようと思います
なぁに、安心せい
私を誰だと思ってるんじゃい
なんか結構ね、食べてる人を見たことあるんですけども
みなさん口を揃えて
「まずい」とか「無理」とか
お行きになられそうな方もいたんですけど
そこらそこらの人間とこなしてきた危険的食べ物とのバトルが多いので
正直余裕でしょう
開けてみましょう
う〜わ
黒い
中は黒いです
これお菓子じゃないよね
ビタミンBが多そうですね
まぁ、体にいいなら良しでしょう
ダイエットにもいいらしいです。
こんなの、余裕っしょ
もうワンチャンいければ
これ丸ごと全部食おうぐらいの勢いなので
パンなんかにかける時間すらも勿体無い
もうこのまま食べましょう
ダイレクトに
なるほどな
こうやって色で圧迫してくるパターンね
色で俺は強いぞ
みたいな
そういうちょっと威嚇的な態度を取ってきますが
僕はそんなんには騙されないです
いただきます
イェアオ
アァ〜
アカ
ックアア
アァ
ア
ウッ
オエェ〜
ッア
ウ
オエッ
ウエ
オウッ
ちょっと待って…ちょっと待って
やばい、やばいやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
すいません。なめてました。
まっず。
これ、ちょびっととかなら大丈夫なのかな…
ちょびっと食べてみます。
アァァウ
オウ
ィゥアアアウ
え
こ、これマジで言ってんの？
あー、やだこれ
うわぁー、ウェー
きわ、極めてまずい。
これすごいな。
想像してる８倍くらいまずいです。
苦いとかまずいというか
なんか
すごい
環境悪目な土を食べてる味がしました。
食べたことないけどね。
ジャムなんでパンにかけて食べるのが普通なんですよ
いただきやす
わからぬ。
ん〜？あのー
薄くかけると
あのー
まずいっす。
結局まずいぞ。
薄いとありです。
なんか、味の薄いパンにちょっと塗るとおいしくなるっていう気持ちはなんとなく分かる。
が、比較的にまずい。
僕は、割と好きです。
もうパンにかけておいしいのはなんとなく分かったんですけども…
ダイレクトで食べたい。
すごいなんか栄養価の高そうな食品なんですけど、
これをあんなに薄〜く塗って食べてても効果がないんで、
できればもう、ダイレクトで食べていきたいんですよね。
アァウ
というわけで僕はちょっと…
ウワァ〜
これすごいな。マジで。
僕どうしてもダイレクトで食べたいので、
ちょっと、いろんなことを挑戦してみようと思います。
まずはこちら
マヨネーズはこう味をマイルドにする力があるし
マヨネーズ自体おいしんで、あと甘い。
その甘みを上手いこと使えば、ひょっとしたら…
ベジマイトの力を弱くできる可能性があるかもしれない。
うむ、いただきます。
ん？
おっ⁉︎
ゥアアア
アァァア〜
ウェッ
あ、ちょっ
やばっ
あぁ〜、惜しかった。
わずかに、力及ばずという感じです。
次はこちら
ケチャップはですね、トマトを基準に作られているので
その甘みを生かした感じで
いい感じで戦ってくれればいいなと思っております。
いただきます。
俺すごいなぁ。
ん！ん！
オウッ
あ、うは、あっ
アー、あ〜、アアーアー
最初結構コーティングして助けてたんですけど
途中から手を離しました。
最後はもちろんこの方
苦い成分を倒すには、もう、痛覚しかないと
デスソースとこれを一緒に食べると、デスソースの方が強いんで
苦味を感じないかもしれない…
これは結構有効な作戦だと思います。
心の声「もう限界だ。これ以上食べると死んじまう。」
やばばい、やばい。多い…
お、ちょ…
ちょ、気持ち多いいな…
では、いただきます。
絶対大丈夫！
アウッ、アゥェ〜、アー